ここに美味しそうなサンドイッチがあります
でもこのサンド市販売系はあと5秒で切れます
たった今このサンドイッチはゴミ箱に行くしかなくなりました
いっ
このようにまだ美味しく食べられるのに捨てられてしまう食べ物がフードロスと呼ばれ
ています
残念ながらこのフードロスが日本も至る所で発生しているのが現状です
こうしたフードロスに一番影響与えのは当たりだと思いますか
それは私たち消費者です
私も一人の消費者としてこの風通すという課題に3年前から変わってきました
私がフードラスに関わるになったのは小学校2年生の時に白血病を患ったことが
きっかけでした
1年半という長い闘病生活の中で一番つらかったのは食事でした
自分が食べたいものが食べられず子供にとって味付けを過ぎで病院食を毎日食べるのは
とても苦痛でした
看護師さんにおかッくれてカップラーメン食べて怒られてしまったこともあります
闘病生活の後私は食事を制限されていた反動から人一倍食に対して執着するようになり
ついには職人しか興味が湧かなくなってしまいました
その後私は大学生になり食感での仕事を探して私がずっと憧れだったカフェで働き始め
ました
そこでバイトリーダーになった私は発注業務を任せてもらえるようになりました
そこで驚いたのはそのお店が必ず不動素が出るように発注をするマニュアルなっていた
ことです
私の憧れだったカフェはなぜそんなもったいないことをしていたのでしょうか
それはお店が閉店間際まで品揃えをしておくことがいわゆるサービスの一部となってい
たからです
お客様が閉店間際まで商品を選べることがその他いそいその商品が捨てられてしまうと
しても発注すべきという考え方だったのです
私はずっとしてる前提の3不一致を発注してへっ展示ではそれは当たり前のように捨て
ていました
私は自分が食べたくても食べられない時期があったのに今では自分の手で
サンドイッチをせてしまっている
なんでこんなことが当たり前になっているんだろうと働いているあ立つときもんでした
このアルバイトの経験がきっかけで私はフードすという社会課題に興味を持ち
調べるようになりました
その結果わかったのはフードロスはこのお店のせいでもなく誰のせいでもないという
ことです
そもそもフードロスという社会課題はなぜ発生するのでしょうか
それは大量生産大量消費の時代小資本主義社会の中で
てきた考え方が原因となっています
お客様が来店した時に商品がないという機会創出よりも
余るほど生産してせた方が経済的に良いという概念から生まれています
実際世界では毎年13億とものフードロスが発生しています
日本はその中でも取り当たりの年間フードロス量が世界で6番目に多く年間で600
12万トンものフードロスを発生させています
一方で日本の食料自給率は平成30年度のカロリーベースで37%と-9
食料輸入に頼っている状況です
つまり私たちは過剰に生産輸入された食品を食べることなく日々廃棄しています
これは生産過程で消費した資源が無駄になるだけではなく無駄に co2を排出して
環境負荷を上げてしまっていることです
こうした風通すの現状を聞いていると自分の生活に直接影響がない
別日経はその食べ物に困るわけじゃないし方倫理的にダメな事っていうだけでしょと
いう風に捉える方がいますがそれは違います
フードロスという課題が進むと私たち消費者の
今の食べたいものが食べられるという生活が成り立たなくなる可能性があります
例えばコマも世界人口が97億になったときに
限られた食料が常に日本に new されるでしょうか
日本は食料自給率が低くもし何が1移入が止められた場合
国内生産のショックに頼るしかなくなります
そうすると今の私たちの食べたいものが食べられるという暮らしが成り立たなくなる
可能性があります
私たちは今持続可能ではない食生活をずっと続けている状態なのです
話を聞いていると大変なことのように感じられるかもしれません
実は風洞そ人ごとではなかったと
そしてこの現状を解決していくには私たち消費者の働き掛けが不可欠です
火神先ほどデータ現状を聞いていると
もう手遅れなんじゃないか消費者1人が何か頑張っても
を得られる効果を吸いんじゃないかと悲観してしまうかもしれません
しかし私たち消費者がミサがや飲食店に対して
規格外商品でも買いたい
ちーが近いものでも買いたいと意思表示することにより
店側の行動に変化を起こすことができます
実際に消費者が店に働きかけやすくなるように私が取り組んでいることが2つあります
鳥栖がフードシェアリングサービス食べてです食べては近くの飲食店で余ってしまった
ものをお得に購入できる低かつサービスで現在30万人の方がアップに登録して
いただいています
またこれまでに約4万食が救われました
入山は多くは社会貢献ができてうれしいというふうに話しております
また食べてのユーザー約600人に回答していただいたアンケートにて食べての利用
前後でどれほど風同性の関心度合いが高まったかを検証しました
new お前はフードロスへの関心があると回答された方は48%でしたが食べており
用語には94%にまで増加しました
このアンケート結果から雨た食事を食べてを通して購入することにより消費者の風洞
作品への貢献士気が高まったといいます
この食べてを導入した店舗さんはこんなに重要があるとは思わなかった
今まで廃棄していた食品の量を見直すきっかけになったと話していました
これは消費者が買い物を通して社会貢献をしただけではなく店舗側の意識を変える
きっかけになったという一つの手になります
二つ目がレスキューでいいという授業です sq デートは閉店後に駅の中で余って
しまった食品を私たちが安く買い取り駅従業員の方にお得に販売する取り組みですこれ
は実際に東京駅にある駅ナパしつつのヘッデン後に私たちは買い取った食品の写真です
まだまだ食べられるおいしそうなパンやお弁当
by ばこんなからの寮を買い取って販売していました
実際に2020年の1月に1カ月間実施したときには3カ月間で約最もの hulu 数
を削減することができました
参加した飲食店さんにお話を聞いたときに
飲食店さんは
このレスキューでに取り組みで捨てる量がかなり多くヘディ
そのおかげで座薬かも軽くなったと話していました
また当たり前に今まで廃棄していた者が最後まで誰かに食べてもらえるというふうに
あらためて認識が持ったというふうに話していました
このも駅中根の創始者である従業員が
飲食店に働きかけることにより店舗の認識が変わった事例です
ではこのような取組を踏まえて私は消費者フード削減に向けて何ができるのでしょうか
二つ目はフードロス商品あ企画課へ商品を
て店が痛いして積極的に販売を求めそしてそれを買うことです
食べてはレスキューゼリーもその一つですがそれに限らず
フードロシュ商品や規格外商品を買うことで
店側に対してフード商品に需要があるということを知ってもらうきっかけになります
二つ目は sns で発信をすることです
訳あり商品のことてもいいですし不動商品を買ったらそれを購入した時に sns で
発信すること
例えば面白い形のやさ良かったならそれを共有してみんなで楽しむこと
f ドレス9をただの義務や問題解決をとして捉えるだけではなくポジティブなことと
してトレンドにしていくことが必要です
またこれは他の人がそういった商品を知るきっかけになるだけではなくそういった商品
を買うことは当たり前であるという考え方を広げることもできます
3つ目は風洞さつけん取り組むお店を批判するのでを傍観するのでもなくあらゆる形で
応援することです
2年前までは賞味期限の近い消費を販売する店舗に対しては売れ残った商品を販売して
いるだとか腐りかけの商品販売しているというふうに否定的な声が上げられてきました
しかしここ数年メディアや行政の力によって電池拡大が進み
かなりそのイメージが改善されてきました
ん
私たちが本来するべきことは勇気を持ってフード酒に取り組み始めた店舗を否定するの
ではなく
褒め称えることです
立った消費者の応援なくして風洞削減の取り組みは広がりません
ここまで風通すの現状や私は消費者がフードんさつけんに向けるでできることについて
お話してきました
戻すは他人ごとではなく私たち消費者一人一人の生活に直接影響する社会課題です
だからこそ私たち消費者が積極的に取り組んでいく必要がありますこうした取り組みを
通して私たちが風洞さっきに取り組むことができれば誰も食べない食料過剰に生産する
ことを抑え
地球資源の無駄
を減らすことができると私は信じています